But let me refresh you
and take a little recap of her past
so we can talk about the present and the future.
Almost 30 years ago, a shocking incident
rocked the nation and dominated the news.
In a sleepy Virginia town,
Lorena Bobbitt drew global attention
when she dismembered her husband John's private part
with a kitchen knife
and threw it out the car window,
claiming that he sexually assaulted her.
John denied abusing his wife
and claimed he was an abused husband.
Ultimately, Lorena and John
were both charged with separate crimes,
and then both acquitted.
Painted as a vengeful, unhinged wife,
Lorena was a punchline
on late night shows and in headlines,
but maintained that she was a terrified
and trapped young woman
who endured years of alleged domestic abuse
and finally snapped.
Today, Lorena is an advocate
for domestic abuse survivors.
She founded the Lorena Gallo Foundation
and create safe spaces for victims,
providing the support that she says she needed.
Lorena lives with her longtime partner
and their daughter in that same small Virginia town
where she became infamous decades ago.
Her story lives on.
(audience applauds)
Ladies and gentlemen,
please welcome Lorena Gallo!
(audience cheering)
Thank you so much.
Thank you, everybody. Thank you.
Thank you.
I mean, I'm freaking out to meet you. I really am.
let me just say one of the things
that I really admire about you is that
you dismembered your husband,
you chucked it out the window,
you became like the butt of jokes,
and when I see you hearing and talking about it,
you have a sense of humor.
You are in on the joke.
You allow people to giggle or be uncomfortable.
And how do you manage that?
Because I felt like a punchline too. I was washed up.
They're very different circumstances,
but I oddly relate a bit to the feelings
of how do I ever change this narrative about me?
Well, it's part of being human too, actually.
I look at my story as this big tree
that turns into branches.
Yes, we talk about serious issues
like domestic abuse, women's issues,
sexual assault, marital rape,
but also has a bizarre twist into my own story,
which is the jokes and also the humor in it.
And I said to myself, "Well, you know,
I am human too and I have to learn to live with.
And it's very sad to minimize the horrors
that domestic violence implicates on a person."
Because it really drains you,
not only mentally, physically, but psychologically.
It really takes a big step on the women's health
and anybody who is a victim of domestic abuse.
So to actually separate myself from that
and became the punch line of jokes
and people making all kinds of, you know,
I was basically like a cartoon character
that people can't get away from it.
So I have to take
my life back and basically turn it around.
And I said, "Well, it's part of humans to joke about.
It's part of, you know, we leave with jokes all around."
And I had to understand that.
And once you understand that part
that comes with the nature of being human,
then you're basically,
it's part of the healing process.
It took a long time to get to where I am right now.
It's really psychologically.
I mean, I was lucky to have doctors
that help me to go through that process
and to start the healing process.
It took years, I mean,
I can laugh about it and joke about it now,
but really it's not a laughing matter,
you know, the more we talk
and the more we get involved as an advocate
of domestic abuse, sexual assault,
and marital rape, but I have to create a balance.
And I'm a keynote speaker
for colleges and universities.
And when I do that, in order for me to reach out
and to connect with the young generation,
you have to basically introduce humor to it.
And my story has that.
And so, basically, this is my platform
and I utilize it to help others
to escape domestic abuse.
I love that, I love that you are able
to humanize and humor.
I love that you didn't run away.
You still live in this small town.
You are a fierce advocate for women.
I mean, that is the opposite of hiding.
There's so many layers.
(upbeat music)
♪ Oh ♪